l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 181 de Monsieur Antoine
Lefèvre à Monsieur le Ministre du
redressement
productif monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues monsieur le Président pardon
la réflexion des énergies fossiles
implique que les différents acteurs
aussi bien l'état que les entreprises et
les particuliers se préparent au
changement d'habitude et de comportement
en particulier dans le domaine du
transport individuel c'est dans ce
contexte de mutation et de difficultés
de l'industrie automobile classique
qu'il y a tout juste un mois le le 83e
Salon de l'Automobile de Genève ouvrait
ses portes force de constater que
l'industrie automobile est enfin rentré
dans le tourbillon de l'électrique de
nombreuses marques proposent modèles
essentiellement de petite taille à
commencé par Renault avec le modèle Zoe
même s'il convient particulièrement
aujourd'hui d'évoquer le dépôt de bilan
annoncé hier de Liz qui n'a pas pu en
2012 écoul plus de 700 véhicules la mia
électrique en effet en 2012 5660
véhicules électriques ont été vendus
ceci représente 0,3 % du marché français
et jusqu'à 1,75 % si on inclut les
voitures hybrides mais tout de même deux
fois plus qu'en 2011 sur l'Europe de
l'Ouest ce sont ce sont que 24203
véhicules complètement électriques qui
ont été commercialisés soit 0,21 % du
total des ventes or la flotte de
véhicules européennes est très ancienne
et son renouvellement eu égard à la
lutte contre les émissions de CO2
devient urgente malgré les mesures
prises pour relancer les ventes de
voitures par le biais de primes à
l'achat de véhicules hybrides électrique
dont la localisation de production devra
être en France la demande ne semble pas
être encore au rendez-vous or alors même
que la prise de conscience d'une
nécessaire nouvelle approche du
transport se fait jour à l'heure de la
hausse continuelle des prix du carburant
et au soucis d'économie et d'écologie
par partagé par tout un chacun quelles
sont les causes de ce peu d'appétence
pour le combustible alternatif qu
électrique problème d'autonomie prix
d'achat du véhicule frais de réparation
et d'entretien achat ou location des
batteries faible nombre de bornes en
effet le risque de panne par manque de
bornes de recharge est régulièrement
évoqué et il faut bien remarquer que
celle d'ors et déjà installé le sont
essentiellement en milieu urbain la
recharge ne pouvant se faire que sur des
bornes dédiées ou des prises spécifiques
installées chez le particulier le plein
d'énergie demande près d'une heure sur
une borne publique mais 6 à 7 he à
domicile il n'existerait que 1473 bornes
sur notre territoire dont beaucoup en
panne ou encore peu opérationnel le
département de laine dont je suis l'élu
n'en compterait même pas une seule face
aux ventes très faibles des premiers
modèles en 2012 les constructeurs
déplorent ce manque de bornes qui
pourrai expliquer ces débuts difficiles
comment l'objectif fixé en 2009 de
400000 bornes pour 2020 pourra-t-il être
atteint alors même que les prévisions
sont à peine de 3000 en accès public par
an il convient donc que les États les
villes et les constructeurs coopèrent
afin que les infrastructures nécessaires
soient mises en place alors même que le
véhicule électrique représente un vaste
marché sur lequel le gouvernement a
parié en priorisant sa construction il
ne faudrait pas que l'offre faite aux
consommateurs voit sa diffusion freinée
par manque d'alimentation si la France
paraît actuellement faire figure de prou
dans le développement d'électrique il
est bien évident que pour relever le
défi d'une utilisation de masse du
véhicule électrique un cours d'usage et
de maintenance inférieure un cooupt
d'usage pardon et de maintenance
inférieure à ceux des véhicules
thermiques en seront les déclencheurs
merci donc monsieur le ministre de nous
indiquer un état des lieux des mesures
de déploiement de ces bornes au-delà du
plan automobile présenté en juillet 2012
et de la mission hzman du 3 octobre et
aussi s'il vous plaît de nous donner la
position du gouvernement sur la
situation de lièz je vous remercie merci
la parole est à Monsieur Cader
Arif monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur Lefèvre je vous prie tout
d'abord de bien vouloir excuser le
ministre du ressement productif retenu
ce matin par le comité stratégique de
filière modéux à
Paris avec le plan automobile présenté
le 25 juillet 2012 le gouvernement c'est
vigoureusement engagé pour promouvoir le
véhicule électrique premier lieu l'État
et ses opérateurs montrent ainsi
l'exemple en consacrant 25 % des achats
de véhicules au véhicules électriques ou
hybrid rechargeablebl et cette part est
emportée à 100 % pour les véhicules
urbains le développement du marché des
véhicules électriques a été accéléré en
augmentant de 2000 € le bonus pour
l'achat d'un véhicule électrique a été
porté à 7000 €. les premiers résultats
de cette politique ambitieuse sont là
dans un marché auto mobile français
malheureusement en baisse de près de 14
% les ventes de véhicules électriques
ont vu leur vente multiplié par 2 que ce
soit les véhicules particulers ou les
camionnettes qui totalisent
respectivement
5663 et
3651 unités vendu l'an dernier contre
2630 et 1683 en 2011 sur les deux
premiers mois 2013
898 véhicules particuliers électriques
et 874 VUL électrique ont été
immatriculé soit 1772 au total
confirmant la progression de 2012 cette
croissance devrait se prolonger portter
par l'arrivée vous l'avez indiqué de
nouveaux modèles de Renault ZOE et PSA
Berlingo et partenire par ailleurs pour
accompagner les initiatives des
collectivités territoriales auxquelles
les lois Grenel ont confié la compétence
pour le déploiement d'infrastructure de
recharge l'État a lancé en janvier 2013
un nouvel appel à manifestation
d'intérêt doté de 5 50 millions d'euros
sur les fonds du programme
d'investissement d'avenir et ouvert à
toutes région à toutes les régions
départements groupements de villes et
communauté d'agglomération de plus de
200000 de 200000 habitants pour
implanter davantage de bornes de
recharge ouvertes au public au première
aville 1er avril 2013 ce sont 6500
prises de recharge qui seront implanté
en France contre 1800 en juillet 2012
des premiers projets régionaux ou
départementaux sont en cours de
formalisation il laisse espérer
l'installation de 8000 prises de
recharge avant la fin de l'année nous
souhaitons et vous le savez bien
accélérer le développement de ces
initiativ et sont fortement mobilisés
pour que ces résultats soient encore
plus spectaculaires en 2013 et nous y
travaillons avec l'ensemble des acteurs
en particulier acteurs public et acteur
privés merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur Le
Fèvre bien jeai pas totalement la
réponse monsieur le ministre sur la la
situation de liè c'est peut-être plus
une question d'actualité mais j'imagine
que cette semaine celle-ci sera à
l'ordre du jour je vous remercie
cependant pour votre réponse euh alors
c'est vrai que cette question elle date
pour ma part de de presque 6 mois euh
nous avons vu qu'elle était d'une
brûlante actualité euh entre-etemps
c'est tenu effectivement le 6 février
dernier une réunion de la caise des
dépôts autour du coordonateur de réseau
des infrastructures de charg et
également la responsable du programme
véhicule électrique du futur de de
laadem son objectif vous l'avez rappelé
était de présenter au col collectivité
locale des dispositifs de déploiement
des infrastructures de recharge l'aide
que vous avez évoqué des des 50 millions
effectivement été mise en œuvre elle est
plutôt bienvenue elle est de 50 % pour
les bornes à charges normales seulement
30 % pour les charges rapides et
pourtant ce sont ces ces bornes à charge
rapide qu'il faudrait bien sûr déployer
de façon plus plus rapide sur le domaine
public euh je voudrais simplement
évoquer que nous n'avons pas abordé la
question cruciale de de capacités pour
les constructeurs européens de
s'entendre sur un standard de recharge
commun euh je pense que ça sera
peut-être le message à à à donner à
Monsieur le Ministre Montebourg pour que
on puisse relayer ses inquiétudes auprès
de de Bruxelles dans la perspective
d'une uniformisation à laquelle la
Commission doit doit me semble-t-il
réfléchir il paraîtrait effectivement en
effet que la recommandation s'oriente
vers la prise allemande de type 2 qui
est interdite en France pour des raisons
de sécurité à savoir l'obligation d'un
obturateur donc vous voyez que ce
dossier loin d'avoir trouvé sa vitesse
de croisière je compte sur l'action du
gouvernement pour aider au déploiement